the International Business Times
interviewed Republican senator bob
Corker of corker admits he hasn't read
the final tax bill that's gonna be voted
on this week in the House and Senate but
he is gonna vote for it he also claims
that he had no idea about a last-minute
change to the bill that would personally
enrich him so let's take this in two
parts first of all there's this
provision that was added which allows
people like corker to hide real estate
holdings and also it reduces taxes on
income that one earns from LLC's that
hold real estate and it just so happens
that corker earned 7 million dollars
last year from exactly this type of
income and it also just so happens that
corker changed his vote from no to yes
on the bill after that provision was
added but he says he had no idea about
that provision being there being added
and that it didn't factor into his boat
by the way Donald Trump also lists
between forty and seventy million
dollars of the exact same type of income
on his financial disclosures meaning he
would also benefit this little provision
that corker supposedly knew nothing
about that's part one part two big
picture this doesn't apply just a corker
but corker admits he hasn't read the
bill that he read a summary we're
talking about more than a trillion
dollars in changes hanging in the
balance here
he had a summary he never saw the actual
text of the bill but it's great and he
supports it now I get it right word by
word these are huge bills that's what
your staff is for to some degree but to
say I read a two-page summary from the
leadership of the Republican Party
that's not due diligence that's not
responsibility to your constituents and
then of course the straight up lying
hypocrisy hybrid that's become kind of
the calling card of Republicans under
the Trump administration he told NBC
News that he wouldn't vote for a bill
that adds a penny to the deficit on
October 1st of this year ten weeks ago
and now he's all of a sudden in favor of
a bill it's gonna add about a trillion
and a half dollars to the deficit except
he's voting for it he's voting for it
without even having read the bill and it
benefits him
hugely I guess just hearing that there
is a provision that enriches you is
enough you don't even have to read the
fine print of the bill at that point and
to add to this corker is just one of the
senators that has received or not
necessarily received but who had
provisions added either because of their
involvement or through no involvement of
their own that personally benefit them
financially not even time to cover them
all there's bob Corker will let you know
whether this ultimately passes later
this week